physicists are excited and they say this
could be a major breakthrough in our
understanding of the universe it all has
to do with the behavior
of subatomic particles called muons
experiments at a lab near the u.s city
of chicago have shown that muons move at
a rate that's faster than expected
potentially unlocking the secrets of a
previously undiscovered
fifth force of nature
[Music]
this could be the door to a whole new
world of physics
for years researchers have been using
this ring made of superconducting
magnets
to accelerate the tiniest building
blocks of mata
called muons until they're almost
as fast as the speed of light that's
when they can observe how muons interact
with other forces and particles
and the results show that muons actually
behave completely different
to how current theory says they should
up until now
something called the standard model
explained all subatomic particles and
their characteristics
such as charge mass and lifespan
but scientists have observed that the
behavior of these muons suggest
particles and forces exist outside of
this theory
everything that we can see in our
universe everything around us
can be explained by a few building
blocks
these blocks describe the standard model
of particle physics
one group of these particles makes up
matter
the others transfer force this theory
can explain three of these forces
but the fourth force gravity can't be
explained in this way
this is the force that keeps planets in
their orbits
and that affects everything that has
mass
when the universe was created by the big
bang
these four forces combined that's why
the standard model can't explain what
exactly happened
at the beginning of time
the muons experiment could help us plug
these fundamental gaps in our scientific
knowledge
and help us solve mysteries that have
been confusing astrophysicists for
decades
but first more exact measurements and
testing needs to be carried out
to make sure the muon's unexplained
behaviour
really can be attributed to unknown
particles
or forces
all right the mystery of the muons to
talk about that i'm joined now by alex
keshavarsi a research associate in the
department of physics and astronomy at
the university of manchester in the uk
it's good to have you on the program so
how excited are you about this discovery
well i think it's fair to say that we're
plausibly excited
we've taken a very very precise
measurement of the behavior of muons as
you explained in your intro
and done a very very precise calculation
of what that behavior should be and we
found that they don't agree
and what this hints at is that there
could be new particles or forces
contributing to the way that the muon
behaves with the rest of the universe
i mean now i'm so plausibly excited
because we measured this
for the first time about 20 years ago
and statistically it's there's about one
in the 40 000 chance this could be a
fluke that this could be
you know messed up and the gold stand
that we set it by is
1.3.4 in 3.5 billion that's that's the
the stand that we want to set and as we
go forward with the experiment that we
will hopefully reach
well we heard in that report that this
could be proof you know
plausible proof that um this could we
could have an
unknown force out there or unknown
particles so explain
to the layman here among us what exactly
does that mean
well what it means is that by comparing
this very precise measurement with this
very
size calculation is that we've shown to
an extreme likelihood
that there's something about the
fundamental structure of the universe
that we really don't understand
and if that new measurement and this
discrepancy between the two
would stand up and would would stand the
test of time
it would be proof that there's something
missing in
the model of our building blocks of what
the universe is made of
and now this could be a new force like
you said um in the intro it could be a
new particle but
it will in general influence the
universe around us and all of its
contexts including muons
and in that sense we'll define a new
paradigm in how we look at what the
universe is made of
could it possibly help explain some of
the biggest
mysteries in the universe
yeah so there are several big mysteries
that um
most physicists agree uh that are
are present and we can't explain they're
for the the largest being that we don't
really know what 95 percent of our
universe is made of
um we know that 70 of it is made of
something called dark energy
which is what we use to explain why the
universe is expanding an accelerating
rate
and there's also the other 25 is dark
matter
and we know that the dark matter has to
be there because it influences
parts astrophysical parts of the
universe when we look out to the stars
but we don't know what that dark matter
is and it could be that should this
uh this result from the mu1 g102
experiment in chicago
be proved to be a new physics discovery
that it could be that source of dark
matter that as of yet we haven't found
well let's say that the numbers are in
your favor and that this discovery
um turns out to be real are we going to
have to rewrite
the physics books
well yes and no i mean the the standard
model
that was described in the intro works
very very well and describes a lot of
the universe around us and we can do
tests
and show those to be correct but it's
still true that if this result was to
stand up it will be
something very fundamental about the
structural universe
the structure of the universe that we
haven't yet observed and clearly there's
something missing given
what we see when we look out the stars
and everyone accepts this
um but if we discover a new force or a
new particle it will open up a new era
in attempting to understand what
constitutes you know
the matter all around us alex kishavarzi
helping us
understand the mystery of the muons it's
fascinating
alex thank you thank you thank you very
much
you